- Being diagnosed
definitely saved my life,
and I'm very open about that
because I think it's not something
that's talked about enough.
Autism, first of all,
is very underdiagnosed,
especially in women because
it presents differently.
Growing up, I always felt so different,
and I felt like I didn't belong.
I didn't understand why I was interested
in different things,
or when it came to social communications,
like, there was this disconnect.
I didn't understand why that was.
I felt very isolated and separated,
and I wasn't happy with who I was,
and I felt like I had to change that.
(bright music)
My name is Olivia Schlaepfer.
I'm a senior here at Yale College,
and I'm in the
Environmental Studies major.
I am neurodiverse, I am
autistic, and I also have ADHD.
Since being diagnosed and
since being here at Yale,
I've really come into my own.
I accept who I am and I'm
also a lot easier on myself
because I know my brain
is structured differently
and that comes with so
many amazing things.
Like, I delight in such
a very rich experience
in this world from a sensory perspective.
I feel very connected
to our natural world.
That's why I'm in an
Environmental Studies major,
but it does also lead
to some difficulties.
Some of the things that I
struggled academically with,
in my first year before
getting diagnosed, for example,
in long lectures, during class,
I'd have a lot of trouble sitting still,
especially lecture formats.
I couldn't stay focused
for that amount of time.
If professors were just writing
things on the chalkboard
and there weren't slides
for me to consult,
I felt very lost.
I had a lot of trouble
being able to stay focused
and take notes.
Even though I wanted to learn,
there was some block where I couldn't
and that led to a lot of anxiety
because I felt, like, I
didn't know what was wrong.
I didn't know why I wasn't
able to do the things
that I'd been able to do in the past,
or I didn't know why other
people weren't struggling
with these things.
I'd go into exams and it
would take me a lot longer
to understand the questions,
and sometimes I'd be so
sure that I understood it
and yet I would interpret it differently
and I would misinterpret it,
and I wouldn't understand why that was.
And I also wasn't able to finish exams
because it would take me longer
to be able to sort through the material
or to understand the question.
I would have to be, you know, asking
like raising my hand
and I would feel very
awkward and uncomfortable
having to clarify things
and then maybe the professor
wouldn't understand
why I didn't understand and
I also didn't understand,
and there was a lot of uncertainty
and that did create a lot of anxiety
and being able to get this diagnosis
to educate myself on, okay,
this makes so much sense.
I have all of these answers
now to why I feel this way
and why I experience the
world the way that I do.
And it's so much knowledge that I have now
and that's really allowed
me to accept myself.
And that's why now I'm
so open about things
is because I want to help other people
and be a voice for
those who are struggling
and don't know why
and haven't reached out for
help yet or in the process
and aren't feeling like
they love themselves
for who they are.
And I want to show that
it's okay to be different
and being neurodiverse is beautiful,
and it allows us to bring
a different perspective
to this world.
(upbeat music)
For students coming into
Yale who are autistic
or have ADHD or another disability,
I know that it can be
stressful and overwhelming
and you don't know where to start.
It's a new environment.
You're coming into college,
and it really does take you
out of your comfort zone.
It can be intimidating to
approach professors and be like,
"Actually, I do experience
the world in a different way.
I do learn differently."
But I would say my experience
with professors has been
overwhelmingly positive.
I would say just at the
start of the semester
to open that door for
communication and to be honest.
Professors are people, too.
They're people who have
their own world experiences
and can probably relate
to a lot of the struggles
that you go with, you deal with,
even if it's not
precisely in the same way.
(bright music)
You have so many different
resources to help you here,
whether that's your first-year
counselor, your dean,
your head of college, also
Mental Health & Counseling,
Student Accessibility
Services, Poorvu Center.
There's so many different avenues
for you to get the help
and the support you need.
And I think there is still a
lot of stigma about, you know,
getting support,
getting whether that
be tutoring or therapy
or academic accommodations
because it can make you feel less than,
like, "Oh, I'm not good enough."
But that's not how you should see it.
It should be, it's not that
you're not good enough,
it's that you learn in a different way.
Our academic system is set
up for a certain neurotype,
for people who learn a certain way,
and academic accommodations
that helps to level the playing field
and to ensure fairness.
It's not giving a leg up
or it's not oh, extra help.
No, it's allowing for there to be fairness
and ensuring there's an even playing field
so that everyone here at Yale can thrive.